tu es et reg zemmour n'est pas encore
officiellement candidat premièrement
deuxièmement et régime on n'a jamais dit
qu'il souhaitait être
concourir ou au congrès des républicains
est ce que c'est le dessin à concourir
n'est pas le bon mot mais participer au
congrès c'est un problème pour moi je ne
vois pas selon quelle cohérence et
eric zemmour est un homme intelligent et
cohérent donc je ne vois pas comment on
peut d'un côté
critiqué les républicains comme il le
fait et de l'autre vouloir participer
eux à leur congrès donc je ne vois je ne
verrai pas de cohérence à une telle
démarche
c'est uniquement ça ou est ce que vous
dites ne partagent pas nos valeurs ou
alors il ya se partagent nos valeurs
alors il faut avoir un certain respect
pour l'homme
ah mais moi je je je pense que le
diaboliser est une erreur c'est
quelqu'un qui dont on partage les
constats ou qui partagent les nôtres
plus tôt dans ce sens là sur la question
les questions qu'ils évoquent de
souveraineté nationale or justement
c'est donc aucune difficulté à partager
avec lui ce constat maintenant santé des
valeurs communes avec les sur certains
points alors sur l'amour de la france
sur la souveraineté nationale sur bien
sûr ce sont des choses que nous
défendons aussi mais il ya un certain
nombre de choses sur lesquelles nous ne
sommes pas d'accord ses déclarations sur
l'attentât toulouse m'ont choqué celle
sur péta m'ont choqué et puis au delà de
ça c'est quelqu'un qui sont l'essence
même est la polémique c'est un peu les
must de talent de sur lui vaut d'être
agressé dans la rue ce qui est ignoble
mais mais vous savez aujourd'hui
lorsque les opinions s'expriment
clairement
c'est ça devient un risque et
il a été menacé comme d'autres dans
notre famille politique ont été menacés
nadine morano eric ciotti dès lors que
vous vous attaquez valérie boyer dès
lors que vous vous attaquez au phénomène
de la radicalisation islamique vous
devenu une cible et vous c'est à cet
instant que j'aime vous semblez quand
même moins catégorique que certains dans
votre parti et sur eric zemmour est ce
que pour vous ils partageront à la haye
ce qu'eric zemmour aujourd'hui vous le
conseillons je vais faire un homme de
droite jonah hex je viens je viens de
vous dire vous me démontrer un certain
nombre de différences il y en a une
autre qui est majeur c'est que eric
zemmour prône lui prône l'union des
droites ça c'est une ligne rouge que
nous n'avons nous ne souhaitons
absolument pas franchir la discussion
avec le recensement national mais non
entre les a mais non il ne peut pas y
avoir de discussions entre appareils et
l'air et le rassemblement national
tout simplement parce que le
rassemblement national ne souhaite
qu'une chose c'est la mort des
républicains
[Musique]